all right we got an opponent
24 39 let's go let's go e4
[Music]
and uh we're playing as candy okay so
knight c3 is the move
boy g-hub subbing himself thank you for
the tier one okay so queen d8
is is one of the possible retreating
moves
by by the queen and uh the move here is
of course to play d4
and to develop our pieces normally
knight f3
bishop out to c4 we seek the most active
squares for our pieces now b5 is already
pretty weird
and i'm not entirely sure you know what
this move achieves other than create
some weaknesses
so let's complete our development let's
castle now where should this bishop go
where does the bishop on c1 belong in
these kinds of positions
so we just need to find the most active
square and in my
in my to in my view the most active
square well y f4 i mean we can put it on
f4
g5 yeah bishop f4 is a good move because
it also supports the move knight e5
we're going to slam our knight into the
center
and the bishop does a nice job making
sure that that knight is is more stable
i also like the g5 score for the bishop
so so why not white is slightly better
here it's not
not like black's position isn't terrible
okay so he plays knight to knight to d5
now
it's tempting to take the knight here
but that would give him an improved
center
and uh this is one of those situations
where you just have to keep the tension
so we're just going to drop the bishop
back and i don't mind it if he takes on
c3
and seemingly ruins my pawn structure so
after the game okay
it won't yeah i won't have to do it
after the game i'll explain it during
the game why is this
uh deficient pawn structure not actually
as deficient as it looks well
there's a couple of things first of all
he's gotten rid of his knight
which means that if we look at this
bishop on b3 it now is operating
relatively uncontested along this
diagonal the second thing is
and i've explained this on several
occasions there is a visual deficiency
in this pawn structure but on the other
hand we have a lot of pawns in the
center
and they are defending each other so on
the one hand this may
look bad but it's actually a very solid
pawn structure
okay so we should play a4 we shouldn't
let him uh trap our bishop let's go a4
and um rook bishop a6 okay so he clearly
creates
an x-ray against my rook what should we
do
how should we respond to this move very
simple again no need to overthink it
all right brandon i'll play one game and
then and then i'll be ready for you
yeah so simply rookie one and now you
should immediately
start thinking about various sacrifices
and in particular what sacrifice
or semi sacrifice am i thinking about
here uh
looking at these pawns on e6 and on f7
these pawns are quite a bit unprotected
i mean they're
they protect each other but that's right
about it
um so there's a very thematic idea here
which is to take on f7 to remove the
defender on the e6 pawn in fact
let's do it knight takes f7 i'm going to
do that pretty intuitively
because at the very least at the very
very least
we are going to get uh two pawns and a
rook
for two pieces which is already a good
amount of material
but uh my bet is that we're going to get
more than that
if i play this correctly thank you
software house for the prime
because if we look around the board you
guys should notice the rook on a what
can we say about that rook well that
rook is undefended
which means that what are we threatening
here in addition to just taking the rook
what
how what follow-up okay so he defends
against that but what follow-up were we
threatening
we were threatening a fork on f3 yes all
right now we really have a
have a wide choice and we have to figure
out what our priorities are now
it seems to me it seems to me that it
probably makes sense to try to get this
rook
uh and attack this rook as much as
possible while we have the chance we
don't want to take on f7 prematurely
because that rook isn't going anywhere
it's pinned so
let's go let's go queen h5 let's get the
queen out and let's put even more
pressure on this rock
hopefully that's going to lead to
something good
and this concept is a very important one
the fact that we're not in a hurry
to take the rook a lot of people would
grab that rook first and think later
but uh we obviously don't need to do
that because we're not in a hurry and
now
um again we have several approaches to
this position
we are still not in a hurry so we can
take other stuff first let's play
a takes b5 first and notice that this
pawn on b5 stops his knight from getting
out to a6 or c6
so he's completely paralyzed on the king
side we have three pawns now
and um you know and bishop takes f7 is
going to come at some point we still
don't need to take
we can still move our queen and we're
still going to be able to take his rook
at our convenience now we have a very
crafty move with our queen
very clever little move to e2
could somebody tell me what the idea is
of this move why are we bringing the
queen
specifically to e2 and not to say g4 or
h3 or d1 what are we accomplishing with
this move thank you caulisten life
yeah so we're looking out at that bishop
he has to move the bishop
but now we think about well what is he
weakened
by playing bishop f6 what is he left
unattended or at least relatively
unattended
if we think about it we ask ourselves
that question well notice that the queen
is overloaded
because on the one hand the queen is
tasked with defending
um f7 on the other hand it kind of has
to take on
c5 so dc is a very simple move here
which kind of overloads the queen
and uh he can take on c5 i mean i don't
see a checkmate there
but in the event that he does we can
just bring the rook in and then we can
take on f7
and just crush him in the center and on
the king side
so he can also play bishop takes c3 i
know perhaps some of you are worried
about this move okay so he does play
queen 65.
now notice that we still have not taken
his rook and
i look at the rook on a1 and i say this
rook could be occupying a super
juicy open file on d1 which we're gonna
do and only on the next move
when all of our pieces are in the game
are we going to take his rook
and go after his king we had other ways
to win i think we could have taken
immediately and done queen e8
and bishop takes b8 i'll show that after
the game but
i think this is the most clinical method
because it ensures uh that all of our
pieces are in the attack
which gives us almost this kind of
insurance right if something doesn't
work out
uh it's it's a good idea to have all of
your pieces involved
because then you're going to have quite
an abundance of
of resources in case what you wanted to
do initially isn't as good as
you may have thought
okay so now we can do what we were
planning to do on the previous move we
take on f7
and now between these two checks queen
e6 or queen eight which one do you guys
think i should give
well queen eight is not checkmate but
queen e8 is the better move
and the reason for that is a very simple
one we want to put the rook on d7 but we
can't
he has got a knight on b8 that's
guarding that square but we can actually
just take that knight
we simply win the night but the point of
that move isn't so much to win the night
although that's a nice
um byproduct of that the point is to get
that get our rook to d7 which is going
to be
the killer blow to black's king so black
is absolutely busted here
he's out of defensive pieces and his
king is just toast
not to mention he's now down in exchange
so
he just left his center unattended and
that's what happens
when you do that okay queen g5 we still
have to be careful
uh because he is threatening checkmate
in one move now what would be the
simplest winning move here
and i always advocate for this rather
than going headfirst into the
complications
we have a very simple move here that
doesn't require
any calculation and it wins the game on
the spot
so and the move here is well it's not f3
f3 is a little bit too passive
if we look at this bishop we can notice
that it's undefended
the bishop on b7 is undefended and um
we can either play rook d7 rook takes b7
but i even like queen between d7 and
queens xb7
because that wins the bishop um
you know and attacks the rook on 88 at
the same time so queen d7
and her resignation from black brandon
i'll be ready in just a second
so that's basically that um and that was
a nice game i mean that wasn't anything
extraordinary
but it was candy we developed all of our
pieces
okay we developed all of our pieces so
so b5 is already a little bit dubious
uh because while this move does grab
space on the queen side
it has a there's a negative part to it
which is that it creates
a backward pawn on c6 and it saddles him
with these queen side weaknesses which
actually later came back to bite him
so e6 also i would probably develop my
bishop
uh behind the well in front of the pawn
chain before playing e6 so he developed
a little bit passively
although he didn't do anything terribly
wrong um
95 95 and here was i think the first
critical moment i think a lot
of people would be tempted to take on d5
but this you know this actually helps
black bring another pawn into the center
it shuts down the bishop
look at my bishop now it's just biting
on this d5 pawn
and black builds up this very nice pawn
chain and
um you know white doesn't really have
anything to show for maybe white is
slightly better here
it's very very important to resist the
temptation uh to you know to do this
kind of stuff to capture a piece
just because it's uh it's tempting to do
so
okay so bishop g3 um and he takes on c3
i think this is actually a mistake
i think this is actually a mistake
because it as i explained it does two
things
both of which are good for white the
first is that it leaves me with a very
strong diagonal
this bishop on b3 is now essentially
uncontested
along that diagonal which creates these
tactical opportunities such as knight
takes f7
uh the second thing is that these pawns
are actually good
even though they're doubled even though
they're isolated uh
you know i call this like shedding your
skin we can play the move c4 in the
future
let's just let me just play a random
move for the sake of illustration
and the great thing about this is that i
can then push my other pawn up to c3 and
i can get the best of all worlds
i can disrupt his his queen side pawns
and
still have that central pawn chain as a
consequence
of the fact that i have two c pawns so
that's why i'm on a crusade to show
people that double pawns are actually
kind of good okay so we a5 is met with
a4
and now bishop a6 is almost the decisive
mistake i just think he didn't realize
that these pawns although they protect
each other are very much susceptible
to this kind of a tactic um i think that
my opponent should have probably done
some damage control maybe gone queen v6
and tried to get this knight out of
there
as quickly as possible although black is
already in quite a bit of trouble here
so bishop a6 rookie one c5 and
this is really our only chance to play
knight takes f7 if we
if we screw around and we could also
play queen f3 that might have even been
a better move
but if we screw around too much if we
play the move d5
what does black have here black has a
very nasty little move
which shuts down our bishop what move am
i talking about
well that and that's exactly what i'm
getting too curious
so the move is c4 and we don't want our
bishop to be shut down so we really only
have this one opportunity
to get the bishop to e6 so that the move
c4 is no longer effective now if he
plays c4 here
uh then he loses his queen or taking on
f7 and attacking his
his queen now another question would be
what
what
would have happened if he taken on f7
with a king and
although he doesn't lose the exchange
here i mean the king is very easily
checkmated with a couple of very natural
attacking moves and
his position just collapses here you
should just see that visually
there's really nothing to calculate here
so rook f7 bishop e6
he plays bishop b7 once again if he
would have played knight c6
white supply and win who can find the
most technical
winning idea how do we
go about winning this and i actually
kind of mentioned the correct idea
already um but
we can just apply yes so so we need to
get the order right
yeah queen f3 is good enough but even
taking on f7 first
and then playing queen f3 and picking
off the knight so when your opponent has
a weak kick
uh in addition to looking for checkmate
ideas always look for forks
undefended pieces become particularly
important when your opponent has a very
weak king
because that king is going to be
susceptible to various checks
and if you have an abundance of checks
and chances are one of those checks
might also be a fork
that's why i was paying such careful
attention
to the fact that his rook and a8 was
undefended so
bishop b7 queen h5 and increasing the
attack on his queen and now after queen
fe
we simply play a takes b5 we grab a pawn
we prevent his knight from getting out
to c6 or a6
the rest of the game is very simple we
need to x ring the bishop
then we take upon overloading his queen
we bring the rook into the game
and then the final stage of the game
where we just basically take all of his
pieces
so very simple game we developed our
pieces we seized our tactical
opportunity
and then we didn't rush taking that rook
on f7 we only took it when we were
absolutely ready
to take it and we brought our pieces
into the game first
before taking that rook which made the
attack so much easier to conduct
uh bishop d6 oh bishop d6 is probably
even better yeah
uh oh you want to give a checkmate but
maybe black has queen c8 here
maybe black has queen c8 here and then
of course you can't give this check
because i'm just gonna take your queen
um what do you mean b5 seems
counterintuitive you mean eight takes b5
well not at all i'm just taking a pawn
at the end of the day i'm just taking a
free pawn
that's all i'm doing so it's not
terribly counter-intuitive to just take
a pawn
yeah that was a great game um and
it just shows that if you really adhere
to these basic principles
you can be pretty good players and it
doesn't always take
crazy amount of creativity or
imaginativeness to win these kinds of
games
we're doing the speedo into 2500 120
points of
away okay so let's play ray lopez
despite what i revealed yesterday about
ray lopez
okay so he plays a petrov this is called
the petrov defense
and there's you know there's a lot of
good
good lines against the petrov
but uh one line that sort of flies under
the surface
if he plays the move d6 is the move
knight to c4 that's a bit of an odd move
because it seems to obstruct the
development of the bishop
but um the point is that the knight is
very well placed here and we're going to
get the bishop out to d3
not everybody knows this variation
okay so d5
that's an interesting move okay let's
let's get this knight out of here let's
play knight takes e4
and then next thing is thank you for the
prime and then this pawn on e4 can we
can we deal with this spawn how can we
deal with this pawn
what should we do so
so there's two two different ways of of
playing this
uh we can play the move d3 and and try
to get rid of it directly but another
good way of doing it is to play the move
d4
and either he takes on poisson and helps
our bishop develop or
he has to let this pawn remain on a very
nice central square so he does the
second thing and the bishop can just
come out to e2
remember not every piece needs to be
scaling mount everest at any given
moment
this kind of development is perfectly
good enough and this knight on c4 it's
fine
where it is because it's controlling
it's controlling a lot of central
squares it's nicely placed on c4 that's
not necessarily a very typical square
it's also defended by the bishop so if
he plays bishop e6
which is quite likely then we don't
really have to move the knight away
okay so let's castle and
this pawn on d4 we can see that it's
only defended by the queen
okay so first of all let's deal with
this bishop where should this bishop go
where should the bishop on c1 go should
it go to d2 should it go to e3
should it go to g5 well it shouldn't go
to g5 because he's just gonna take it
it should go to f4 we're also blockading
this pawn if he goes g5 that's very
weakening
i mean he might go g5 but okay he
doesn't
but that would be a very weakening move
okay so now um i feel like
this knight on c4 has overstayed its
welcome and there's a very good night
there's a very good night for this
square there's a very good square for
this night where what what am i talking
about here
that knight is being pressured i know i
know that i said we don't have to move
the knight yeah so e5 is one good square
but even the e3 square i actually like
the e3 score because from e3
the knight potentially supports the pawn
move d5 which would grab more space he
goes g5 i saw this move
the bishop repositions itself to e5
which
is a nice central square and he's he's
really weak in this king so although he
starts this pawn attack
it's a very very double-edged sword what
he's doing okay
now let's make the move bishop c4 let's
try to trade off his bishop and soften
his king up even further
uh i don't think he's worse here but
it's definitely a bit of a tough
position to play for black
but he's playing it very very well so
you know it's anybody's game right now
it takes takes
now our knight is is nicely centralized
but if he plays the move bishop fc
bishop d6 um oh he's played this really
well
uh for sure but um one way that we can
try to exploit
uh the weakness of his king whoops sorry
is is to get the queen out to h5 so
let's do that
all right let's go queen h5 now he can
take our knight in fact i think he
probably will and bliss queen e7
okay so
ideally ideally i'd want to preserve
this knight he's threatening kind of to
capture it well the move f4 allows g
takes f4 and then if rook takes f4 then
he takes on e5 so
there's nothing wrong with making the
occasional retreating move let's play
knight to c4
and then an eventual idea whoops
wow 11 wins and one loss this guy's good
11 wins and one loss so let's let's get
the rook into the game
he lost to a 1600 though in bullet
though in bullet
hmm yeah i'm telling you guys at this
level i i keep playing these weird guys
okay let's go d5 let's get this pawn
into the center
yeah i'm definitely getting the sense
that i'm being outplayed right now
but we'll see so let's go d5 queen g7
okay
let's let's lock him up let's lock up
the queen by playing c3
that game had 99 accuracy no yeah the
pacing i
i could sense in the pacing that
something was a little bit off i can
sense in the pacing that something is a
little bit off
uh it's like you know it's it's the five
seconds of move kind of thing
but it's fine we're gonna we're i mean
i'm still i have a decent position i'm
definitely worse now we're gonna get our
queen back and then he's gonna probably
play a6 let's try to
disrupt the position with a4 so if it's
five seconds of move how many moves do i
have to survive to survive like 40 moves
okay so of course he's gonna think on
eight takes b5
and he's gonna think precisely five
seconds
uh let's go knight c2 let's try to get
it to d4
yeah this is this is looking quite quite
suspicious but
we are going to try give it the old
college try
if i beat this guy then i will go down
in glory
no there's a lot of these people at this
level unfortunately five minute games
you we have seen that it's just it's
just unbelievable honestly
um the amount of people that um
but we're not okay oh rook z3 ah without
rook t3
um
yeah i'm just busted here let's go back
to d4 he's gonna probably play
f3
yeah we we got him down we we boiled him
down to like a minute and a half
the problem is i'm pretty close to
getting checkmated here
i don't play against entrance but how do
i know this guy how did how was i
supposed to know that this guy
is cheating well i don't know i don't
know that he's cheating i'm going to
give him the benefit of the doubt we
always do
we always give these people the benefit
of the doubt and i'm not going to make
any claims
until we check the game with an engine
uh yes the pacing is certainly
suspicious it calls for
for checking him but you know i always
bring up the analogy of imagine that you
were the one playing really well
you know would you want it if people
accused you willy-nilly of cheating and
i think the answer is no
yeah it's the five second moves okay so
i'm gonna play d5 here i mean
i managed to play pretty well here i
think
given the situation how does he actually
win this i'm not sure okay he's below a
minute
now if he goes to work out four i
thought i can give him a check and then
go okay he's got an only move here
and he takes the same amount of time
okay let's play h3 to stop checkmate
no i don't think he's i mean i'm
actually probably not worse here
i don't know it's just the pacing is so
weird
it's literally every move is five
seconds
but i think i'm fine here okay let's
just go queen g3 to prolong the game as
long as possible because i know i'm not
gonna get checkmated
um i know i'm not going to get
checkmated within the next like five
moves and i have a feeling that he's
going to lose on time
or at least i'm going to try to make him
lose on time
i mean just flag him sounds very easy
but when someone's playing this well
it's not that it's actually not that
easy
i'm trying to not get trackmated at the
same time
okay here's another move we survived
another move
oh king h5 okay so let's just go b4 yeah
he's not gonna make it at this rate
king h5 king h4 look at that idea
no he's gone unbelievable and you know
what else is oh and there's a mouse slip
oh my god we got him
ranja moma thank you
all right let's analyze i'm looking
yeah baby strong oh gee
90 92.6 but his last couple of moves
messed with the uh
let's see
[Music]
i mean he's either really good or he's
already i mean he
he played most of his moves were best
oh okay rook f6 is a blunder though
which is a really weird move nobody
would ever play that
yeah and then he started playing best
moves again
wow king h5 is best okay
yeah yeah yeah it's um definitely
very very very suspicious
and and that's honestly why we should
probably stop the five minute speed run
it's very sad but
it's just how it is unfortunately